Good morning, I hope your
having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens, I'm in Sri Lanka.
We are going to a,
Vedda tribe village,
and the Vedda are an indigenous group,
from native to Sri Lanka.
We are gonna go to the village,
we're gonna learn about the culture,
we are gonna experience the culture,
they have arranged to cook local,
this is as native as local Sri Lankan food
as possible from the land.
So it's gonna be a journey,
it's gonna be a learning opportunity,
it's gonna be extremely special,
I'm gonna share the culture, the food,
the entire experience
with you, in this video.
(upbeat ska music)
(car engine roars)
18 bends down the side of the mountain,
but it's so lush, it's so tropical.
It's an amazing road.
(door slides)
Okay, we made it.
Good morning Ruzaina.
- Good morning.
- How are you?
- Fine, thank you.
- Awesome, what is the name of the,
are we in, we're in a small town,
close to a small town, right?
- Yeah, this is called Sor-a-bur-a Wewa
(upbeat drum music)
(distant chatter)
(footsteps crunching)
- [Ruzaina] Whoa.
- Just like a five minute
walk to get to the lake,
to get to the boat.
And then we're gonna take
a boat ride from here,
to get closer to the village,
before we need to take another walk,
to get to the actual village.
Beautiful to be here early in the morning,
it's still so quiet, so peaceful,
not much people, not many people at all.
(talks in foreign language)
(water trickling)
Paddle boats are the best
because it's so peaceful,
it's so quiet, you just see
the ripples of the glassy lake.
(gentle water trickles)
(lively drum music)
We are just pulling up to
the other side of the lake,
and just the view, it's so
peaceful, it's so quiet.
I love how the trees just
come out of the water.
The grass it's so jungly, it's so lush.
Whoa, there's a tree going up there,
but yeah what a spectacular ride,
we made it to the other side,
we're gonna then hike into the village.
(background chatter)
The greenery, the lushness, the wetness,
it's just spectacular,
and it's actually like,
it's not so remote,
there's still took tooks,
there's still motorbikes,
there are small villages,
and homes every now and then.
But it's so peaceful it's so serene.
you see the birds, I just
saw a flying peacock!
I don't think I've ever seen a
flying peacock, wild peacock.
It started raining.
Okay maybe we're just gonna
take cover quickly, right here.
(foreign language)
Hello, hello, oh some tea.
I think you do want one.
(background chatter in foreign language)
(water pours)
It's always perfect
when it starts raining,
and the nearest covering is
a tea house, a tea stall.
So we're gonna use this opportunity,
to have a quick cup of tea
- [Ruzaina] What do you call it?
(foreign language)
- Huh (chuckles) hmm.
- Ah, the kin, the jaggery,
- Yeah it's so special.
- or the tea?
- Both.
- [Mark] Both.
So you just drink a cup of tea
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
- and then you sip on the
tea and then you alternate,
with the, okay I gotta try
that, just take a little nibble.
Oh yeah that's sweet but you taste like
the grainy, like molasses-y.
(child speaking in foreign language)
What is your name?
(speaks foreign language)
- Can you see yourself?
- [Ruzaina] He's so fascinated with it.
- (laughs) Who is that, who's that?
(speaks foreign language) buh-bye.
Okay just a very quick rain,
we're back on the road.
And feeling great,
That tea was some...
- [Ruzaina] Refreshing.
- Yeah, very refreshing,
even though it was hot,
and yeah that cools you.
(upbeat drum music)
(footsteps crunch)
(speaks foreign language)
- Hello, thank you, (foreign
language) nice to meet you.
(foreign language)
- Hello.
(chuckles)
- This is amazing, wow!
And I'm just drenched in sweat,
the humidity has really come
out, cool, thank you Ruzaina.
He is one of the oldest
members from the tribe,
and then some of his
children and some of his,
the people in the village have started,
growing crops in this
area, have started to more,
build schools, there's
doctors, there's small clinics.
Ah, but the older generation
is still living traditionally.
Lots of hunting and
gathering for sustenance.
Yeah this is a learning
experience, a cultural experience,
we've had a warm welcome.
Hello, hello.
Stepping into the family hut now,
all made from mud, and then
there's, yeah there's wood.
Inside the back is the kitchen
hut, where they are cooking.
She has the fire going,
she's cooking uh, something.
But then you can see the whole rack,
where they dry wood, where they dry meat.
They eat a lot of game meat,
that's the method of preserving the food.
Lets go take a look at what's in the pot.
(bubbling)
- [Woman] And they're covered with leaves.
(foreign language)
- [Ruzaina] Okay it's corned
rice, I've never had it before.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah (laughs)
(speaks foreign language)
- She's boiling some
corn, there's some corn,
and beans and looks like coconut,
and then there's like a vegetable stew.
Yeah looks very all natural,
all fresh, looks beautiful.
(in a foreign language)
(man sings in foreign language)
- Calm the babies, when they're crying.
- So he was like showing us.
- [Mark] Ah,
so it's like a song for,
- Babies.
- Ah okay,
so uncle was just showing
us, it's like a traditional,
baby calming song, so he was using the ax,
just to rock the baby, like
almost like a chant of a song.
And now stepping outside,
they've got some game meat,
that there also gonna cook.
So they're getting ready to chop it up.
(village hustle and bustle)
It is diff...
(speaks foreign language)
It's deer meat, which they
caught earlier in the morning,
and then it's already sectioned out,
because they share it with the community.
Oh deer fat.
(speak foreign language)
- By the way Ruzaina
is also making a video,
so go check out her video, she's gonna be,
covering the food but
then also taking it back,
to her kitchen to cook, because
she makes recipe videos.
(foreign language)
Oh that's like a ... whoa.
(upbeat ska music)
(laughs)
- [ Woman] The head is the target,
the head is the target of the...
(upbeat ska music)
- [Mark] Wow, that aim.
- [Man] Okay, okay.
(upbeat ska music)
- Looks like it could backfire
so easily though because
(laughs) oh so you've kind
of got to shoot it sideways.
(upbeat ska music)
- Ah okay, you gotta hold it like this,
and I'm sure you have to
sort of shoot it to the side,
otherwise it will hit the
wood, bounce back at your face.
I won't, oh I can see okay.
(laughter)
Yes I did hit the, okay
wait one more time,
okay angle it, here we go.
Okay (laughs) that went like 10 feet.
That's pretty cool.
Okay we better go see what's
gonna happen with that deer.
In the kitchen she's making some roti,
which is made from a millet flour,
and she mixed in water
and I think that's it.
The oils of the banana
leaf keep it hydrated,
keep it moist so that it doesn't stick,
um that's just like looks
solid and thick and hearty.
(background chatter in foreign language)
And right in the kitchen also is the,
the beetle nut refilling
stations, that's a little.
They have the beetle nut,
they have the leaves,
they also put lime, I'm gonna
try just the beetle nut,
he's shaving one for me with
the leaf, but not the lime,
'cause the lime can really
like burn your gums.
(speaks foreign language)
(leaf crunches)
Ball it up.
- [Ruzaina] Thank you
(laughs) this is awesome.
- I like the taste
though, it's like chalky,
or better yet it's like woody,
it really makes your mouth
water, but then at the same time,
your mouth is like dry at the same time.
That doesn't really make
sense but it's true.
How's the, how's the
beetle chewing Ruzaina?
- Oh, I'm feeling the same thing.
(laughs)
I don't know what's happening
to my mouth right now.
(laughs)
- So she's gonna make the fresh meat,
chopping up some garlic,
some onions are going in,
there's gonna be some spices,
oh the curry leaves, nice.
(pan sizzling)
(foreign language)
(pan sizzles)
First she dried up some spices,
with the curry leaves, it's so fragranted,
this entire hut is just
filled with delicious aromas.
But then in the deer meat
she added more spices,
she added sea salt flakes,
she added turmeric, chili,
she added pepper, she added curry powder,
mixed that around and
then poured that into
the oil curry paste, already
smells unbelievably delicious.
That's gonna be great.
And then lots of spices,
for the gaminess of that meat as well.
(sizzling)
(background chatter in foreign language)
- [Ruzaina] Bye bye, bye bye.
- Here and he's gonna show us,
how to dig out one of the yams,
which is also traditional
food that they eat.
(upbeat drum music)
I think it's a pretty
big size, that's big.
And I think they're gonna
boil that to eat as well.
(calming drum music)
I just wanna ask uncle a couple questions,
maybe about the tribe,
about how long his family has been here.
But we're gonna need like
three sets of translation.
Vedda that's all like indigenous,
Sri Lankan groups right?
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
- But then they have specific tribes.
- [Ruzaina] Yeah they
have specific tribes...
(speaks in foreign language)
What he's saying is that,
like in other countries,
they don't have like a lot
of sections for their tribe,
so they're coming from one
type of, one bloodline sort of,
so then it's called Uru
Warnge, so it's from the pig,
like Ura is pig, so it's from a pig tribe.
- [Mark] Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
(speaks in foreign language)
So traditionally the
tribe would be a hunter,
gatherer society, fish,
hunt, gather seasonal crops,
and produce, use the
lush land of Sri Lanka,
and live off the land.
And so like the skills that
they have, they're expertise,
and their skill at living off the land,
it's a beautiful thing.
But it is not an easy, it's a tough life,
and so lots of the younger generation,
has started growing crops,
have started, more going to school
to become educated to get better jobs.
But it's still important to
remember, important to reflect,
important to acknowledge, to
appreciate the elder generation
and it's such, this is
so incredibly special,
it's such an honor, this is a
privilege just to be sitting,
next to uncle, this is
a moment I will cherish,
and never forget, thank you.
How would you say thank
you in their language.
(man shouting in foreign language)
- I cannot, I cannot
catch that, I'm sorry.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Okay, that's how you say thank you,
(repeats foreign language)
Thank you for having
us (foreign language).
The same millet dry, millet flour,
but mixing it more into like a porridge,
like a paste, over the fire.
The cooking method, the
preparation, and the starch,
it looks so similar to some things,
that I've eaten in
Ethiopia or across Africa,
like such a a similar,
so many similarities.
(in foreign language)
Right out of the fire, she's
molding them into balls,
that's like so burning hot.
(in foreign language)
(upbeat ska music)
Still kind of drizzling but not too hard,
so we're gonna try to eat outside,
they've set all the food out
on mats and banana leaves.
The dishes are, some of them are simple,
but it smells so good, so natural.
The whole grains, the corn, the coconut,
the deer curry is in the center.
(in foreign language)
- [Ruzaina] What you do is you just,
- [Mark] Take the whole thing?
- [Ruzaina] Yeah take,
the whole thing and then
you dowse it with the gravy.
- [Mark] Ah, okay.
- [Ruzaina] So.
- [Mark] He dished to one of these guys.
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
- [Mark] Maybe I'll...
- [Ruzaina] And this is...
- [Mark] Sambol.
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
- [Mark] That looks great.
- [Ruzaina] The authentic one.
- And that's just pure chilies with,
there's nothing else.
- just pure chilies,
- Okay,
- pure chilies,
and salt, yeah.
- maybe salt in there, okay.
- [Mark] It's like dough almost feeling,
I can squeeze in, I'm
just gonna try that first,
just the bean soup.
(upbeat ska music)
- Mm, mm!
(laughter)
- Oh it's amazing.
- Mm hmm!
- Mm, yes (laughs) it's so good.
- Yeah.
- Like the, the grainy
doughiness of the starch,
but then that like gravy with
the beans, it's delicious!
And for this one I'll try the
deer, a chunk of the deer.
(upbeat ska music)
Oh wow!
(laughs)
This deer is amazing,
it's not like the most tender
meat you'll have but like,
it's so flavorful, and
like it's not that tough.
- [Ruzaina] it's not tough.
- Its really good.
Not too tough.
- [Ruzaina] Okay wow.
- So flavorful though, she
added in so much dry spice,
in there like not necessarily
too like chili spice,
but like it's like thick with dry spice.
How do you get the sambol just, it's okay?
- Yeah just stick that.
- Okay.
I'm gonna get some of the
sambol, this is just pure,
pure green chilies into
my bowl, the next bite,
and then gonna go, I'm just
gonna mix everything now,
with the green chilies, with
the deer, with the beans.
Mm mm hmm, sambol is awesome.
Yeah you can taste the
vibrancy of the green chilies.
And then this is the roti made with the,
millet flour as well.
We'll just scoop it up with this.
- [Ruzaina] Gather the deer and the...
- [Mark] Mix it up with the deer,
- [Ruzaina] And the sambol.
- [Mark] with the sambol,
with the everything.
(upbeat ska music)
- It's good.
- It's so good.
It's the same grain, but
completely different texture.
Thank you and there's beans
in here though too right?
- Yeah, beans and coconut.
- beans, corn,
coconut.
- Yeah.
Some more?
- Thank you.
Just reach in it's okay?
- Yeah, it's fine.
- Okay, Thank you.
And that's the yam that they just plucked,
out of the ground like 30 minutes ago.
(upbeat ska music)
(in foreign language)
- [Ruzaina] Ah, the chili
is riding behind you.
- [Mark] Oh nice!
oh yeah, sure sure sure.
- grab one and run (laughs)
give you the herbal drink yesterday,
and then he'll be happy
tonight, even I'm gonna have it.
- Awesome, it's like starchy,
starchy from the corn,
starchy from the beans,
but then refreshing and
crisp from the coconut.
(in a foreign language)
This is the yam,
oh wow!
- [Ruzaina] Good?
- it's like a totally,
different texture, almost like creamy.
And not like really starchy tasting,
kind of like lighter tasting.
Like it's not overly spiced it's not,
but the sambol is wonderful,
and they just showed us that the,
the chilies come from
this plant right here, oh!
A little more chili up in there too.
Whoa, the freshness of that,
it's almost like green bean tasting,
until the spice hit's you.
Now everything is just kind
of mixed with the sambol,
with the beans and rice and the,
oh no the millet and the corn.
(upbeat ska music)
Mm that deer curry is amazing.
Wow, I'm loving it.
The love in the food, the
naturalness, the grains.
Mm would you like chili.
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
- One of the reasons Ruzaina is so cool
(laughs)
she's down to, down to pop chilies.
- Oh yeah!
- Down to pop chilies.
- Cheers.
(upbeat ska music)
They're so fragrant though
- Yeah it's really really fragrant,
but I'm waiting for the
kick, how come that is hard.
- The sambol is spicier
than the chilies, right?
- Maybe they chose the really
hot ones before, and now
these are really young.
- Yeah.
- That one is a little
bit spicy, but like,
it's more fragrant, it's more like,
like almost citrusy, sour.
- Yeah.
- Mama,
(laughter)
Ma-gah ketchup, (speaks
in foreign language).
(in foreign language)
- We just asked uncle, how
old he is, 73 years old!
I thought that he was like 50,
look how young his features are.
Living off the land, yeah.
It was an honor to be in his presence,
to share a meal with him,
even though we don't
speak the same language,
even though we,
I'm sure like our entire thought process,
and world view is totally like opposite,
but just being able to share a presence,
to hang out with him, to sit next to him.
He is an amazing, amazing man.
Thank you.
- [Woman] And have a
little chili on it, better.
(upbeat ska music)
- Whoa, now that hot!
Mm, I have so many
childhood memories of this.
This is one of my favorite snacks.
With that sambol it's starchy,
it's smokey, it's roasted.
That's really good.
(upbeat ska music)
The simple miss of the food,
but everything prepared by
hand, prepared with love,
grown with their hands, and then prepared.
The respect for the land and
for Sri Lanka that they have,
and this is, it's awesome, it's awesome.
(bird sings)
- Yes, we've all just finished lunch,
we are gonna line up for a quick photo,
outside of their home
and I'll say thank you,
to the entire family, to
auntie who cooked, to uncle.
An amazing cook, thank you so much.
(upbeat ska music)
This has been a, an incredible,
memorable experience.
So I want to say thank you,
to auntie for cooking, and everybody.
(applaud)
(in foreign language)
(upbeat ska music)
(laughter)
- Thank you, (foreign language)
- [Woman] Bye!
(in foreign language)
(laughter)
- [Mark] Thank you!
(upbeat ska music)
It's hard to even process
the entire experience,
and then to put it in words,
but all I can say is that,
that was incredibly special.
It was a privilege to have
an opportunity to meet,
to learn from the wisdom,
from the lifestyle,
from the generosity of the Vedda tribe,
and the people that we met,
they were so welcoming,
they had never really done
anything like this before,
and they showed hospitality.
What always touches my heart
in situations like that is,
even when you cannot communicate verbally,
you can still communicate
with your actions,
with your feeling, with the
general like feel of everything.
And so if you can just hang out,
if you can just genuinely
appreciate the food,
if you can smile, if you can
make gestures of positivity,
that's what really comes
through and that's what,
those are the memories
that last, those are the,
the people are just amazing.
And that's one of those situations,
the food I loved the food, I
loved how it was home cooked,
I loved how everybody shared,
has graciously shared that meal with us.
But it was the people, the
community, the sharing,
that's what really stood out.
And so I wanna say a huge thank you,
to the entire village for hosting us,
and especially a massive
thank you for Ruzaina,
she organized everything,
go check her out,
she is THE MINORITY TASTE,
she has such a passion,
and a love for people,
for Sri Lanka, for food.
Finally I wanna say a
big thank you to you,
for watching this video, please remember,
to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it,
leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you
and if your not already subscribed.
And by the way subscribe and
click the little bell icon.
And also check out this
entire Sri Lanka series.
There's traveling through Sri Lanka,
eating lots of incredibly delicious food,
meeting people along the way.
So make sure you watch the entire series,
if you haven't already,
I'll have all the links,
in the description box.
Thank you again for watching,
I will see you on the next video to,
actually right now we're
continuing on to the other side,
to the east coast of Sri Lanka.